FOX BUSINESS.
HAVE A WONDERFUL EVENING.
HAPPY MEMORIAL DAY.
AND ENJOY IT, EVERYONE.
♪
>> Kimberly: HELLO,
EVERYONE, I'M KIMBERLY
GUILFOYLE ALONG WITH GERALDO
RIVERA, PETE HEGSETH, DANA
PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS THE FIVE.
♪
>> Kimberly: IT'S MEMORIAL
DAY THE UNOFFICIAL START TO
SUMMER.
GRAB YOUR MARGARITAS AND HOT
DOG AND LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
IT'S TIME FOR MEMORIAL DAY
FAN MAIL SPECIAL.
WE WILL ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
HOUR.
SO, SHALL WE BEGIN?
ALL RIGHTY.
SO WE ARE GOING TO START OUT
RIGHT AWAY THE INSTAGRAM
QUESTIONS.
ARE YOU GUYS READY?
>> Pete: UM-HUH.
>> Dana: INSTANTLY.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS FROM
TED NURSEY.
I'M DOING MY BEST WITH THAT
THIS IS BASIC MEMORIAL DAY
QUESTION.
DO YOU GO HOT DIGITY DOG OR
GO HAMBURGLAR.
>> Greg: ARE YOU ASKING ME?
YOU SAID GRAB YOUR
MARGARITAS.
STARTING OFF CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION.
WE SHOULD BE DRINKING PANTS
BLUE RIBBON.
>> Kimberly: THE LATINOS AT
THIS END OF THE TABLE LIKE
DORITOS.
>> Greg: S
>> Greg: HOT DOGS OR
HAMBURGERS I'M A HOT BURGER.
EATING A HAMBURGER WITH MY
SHIRT OFF.
>> Kimberly: WOW.
SPARE US THAT IMAGE.
>> Dana: WHY DID I THINK
THAT WAS FUNNY.
>> Greg: IT'S COVERING UP.
>> Kimberly: DANA, I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT THAT.
HOT DOG OR HAMBURGER.
>> Dana: ON MEMORIAL DAY OR
IN GENERAL.
>> Kimberly: I WOULD SAY
MEMORIAL DAY.
>> Dana: I GOLD HOT DOG.
I DON'T HAVE HOT DOGS
REGULARLY BUT MEMORIAL DAY
IS A SPECIAL OCCASION.
>> Kimberly: DOES IT UPSET
YOU?
>> Dana: NOT AT ALL.
I'M VERY COMFORTABLE WITH
THE HOT DOG.
>> Kimberly: WHAT ABOUT
PETER?
>> Greg: BLOOD PUDDING.
>> Pete: SEMPER FI.
>> Kimberly: YOU WILL WANT
BOTH.
>> Pete: GREAT PANDERING
SAGE MITT ROMNEY.
MY FAVORITE MEAT IS HOT DOG.
SECOND FAVORITE MEAT IS
HAMBURGER.
NOT STEAK BECAUSE COMMAND OF
THE PEOPLE.
OF COURSE IT'S BOTH.
HOT DOG FIRST AND AS MUCH AS
A HAMBURGER YOU CAN GET AND
THEN BACK TO A HOT DOG.
RUNNING THING THROUGHOUT THE
DAY AS THE GRILL GOES.
>> Kimberly: HOT DOGS LOOK
IN DANGER TOO MANY PEOPLE
ARE GRABBING THEM.
GET THAT ONE FIRST AND THEN
MOVE TO THE BURGER.
>> Dana: BUN OR NO BUN?
>> Greg: IF YOU DON'T HAVE
AN EVEN MATCHUP OF DOGS AND
BURGERS.
>> Pete: PUT IT ON A BURGER
BUN.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S BEEN
DONE AS WELL.
GRIFF GRIFF MITT ROMNEY HAD
AN ELEVATOR FOR HIS CAR.
>> Kimberly: WHETHER YOU
HAVE YOUR MEMORIAL DAY WAR
WAY.
>> Pete: YES.
>> Kimberly: HOT DOG,
HAMBURGER?
HERALD
>>RALD
>> ILD
>> I GO FOR THE NATHAN'S HOT
DOG KOSHER DOGS.
>> Kimberly: I LOVE
HAMBURGERS AND ALSO HOT
DOGS.
I PROBABLY EAT TWO HOT DOGS
EVERY WEEK.
I HAVE THOSE KOSHER
NATIONAL, HEBREW NATIONALS.
QUITE TASTY.
>> LOST AN HOUR OF LIFE FOR
EVERY HOT DOG YOU ATE.
>> Kimberly: IS THAT TRUE?
>> MAYBE I MADE THAT UP.
>> Kimberly: TWITTER
QUESTION.
GREG, YOU LOVE TWITTER.
THIS YOUR PLAYGROUND.
AT WENDY LADY AND J.
FAVORITE BARBECUE FOOD.
I KNOW YOU LIKE BARBECUE.
>> Greg: FAVORITE BARBECUE
HAS TO BE RUDE
HAS TO BE RUDIBAGA.
SCREW THE RIBS AND STEAK AND
BURGER.
YOU WON'T BE STORY.
>> Kimberly: EAT IT IN THE
WINBEGO.
>> Pete: IS THAT A
VEGETABLE?
>> Greg: YES, IT IS.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
BARBECUE FOOD?
>> Dana: I GUESS COAL
>> Dana: I GUESS COLL
>> Dana: I GUESS COLESLAW.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T BARBECUE
IT.
>> Dana: YOU BARBECUE CORN.
>> Kimberly: GOOD ONE.
MICROWAVE WITH A WET TOWEL
TWO MINUTES PER EAR.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW YOU
KNEW THAT THAT IS A GOOD
LITTLE TIP.
>> Pete: I'M THE THIRD
PERSON TO ANSWER ABOUT
BARBECUE AND WE VENT TALKED
ABOUT MEAT YET.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WORKS.
I'M GOING TO SAY RIBS AND
PULLED PORK.
AND ESPECIALLY IF THEY ARE
DONE REALLY WELL.
I'M NOT GOOD AT IT I DON'T
DO A LOT OF HARM BARBECUING
PRETTY SIMPLE.
STEAKS.
>> Kimberly: PHENOMENAL.
EVEN WHEN I ORDER CHINESE
FOOD I GO WITH THE SPARE
RIBS.
>> Pete: VERY DANGEROUS.
>> Greg: NOT AS DANGEROUS AS
FOR THE PIG.
>> RIBS WELL COOKED.
CRISPY, BURNT.
AND CORN ON THE COB.
>> Kimberly: I LIKE CORN ON
THE COB.
BUTTER, NO BUTTER.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S NOT
BUTTER.
FABIO WHAT'S A BARBECUE
WITHOUT FABIO.
>> Greg: I WOULDN'T CALL IT
A BARBECUE AT ALL.
NOT ENOUGH FABIO MEAT THERE.
>> Kimberly: SITUATION WITH
THE RIBS.
YUM.
>> DID YOU DATE FABIO.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE SET ME UP
WITH HIM.
>> Greg: I TRIED TO SET HIM
UP WITH FABIO.
SHE WAS INVOLVED WITH
SOMEBODY ELSE.
I BELIEVE IT WAS YANNY.
>> Kimberly: OR WAS IT
LAUREL?
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
>> Kimberly: WHAT ABOUT
THIS?
WHAT A WEIRD SHOW.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
TRADITION TO KICK OFF
SUMMER?
THAT'S FROM SARA.
>> Greg: PROBABLY WHEN WE
GET THINGS OUT OF STORAGE,
LIKE AUNT HELEN.
I DON'T HAVE ANY -- I DON'T
THINK I HAVE ANY.
I LIVE IN AN APARTMENT IN
NEW YORK.
THE ONLY THING YOU DO IS
TURN ON THE AIRCONDITIONING
AND HOPE IT WORKS.
THAT'S MY TRADITION.
>> Kimberly: THEN YOU KNOW
THINGS LOOK FAVORABLE.
DANA?
>> Dana: NOT KICKING IT OFF.
WHEN THE DOGS ARE NO LONGER
ALLOWED ON THE BEACH.
MEMORIAL DAY TO LABOR DAY
THE DOGS AREN'T ALLOWED.
GIVE THEM THEIR ONE LAST BIG
FREEDOM SESSION.
>> Pete: SERIOUS FOR A 60
SINCE MEMORIAL DAY IS
KICKOFF FOR SUMMER.
IT'S MEMORIALIZING THIS DAY
AND TALK ABOUT BARBECUES AND
SHOULD HAVE FUN.
FIRST THING YOU NEED TO DO
IS REMEMBER ALL THOSE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO GAVE
EVERYTHING SO WE CAN SIT AT
THIS TABLE TODAY.
I KNOW EVERYONE AT THE TABLE
KNOWS THAT IF YOU HAVE KIDS,
SIT THEM DOWN AND TELL THEM
WHY THIS DAY MATTER.
WHY WE HAVE THIS DAY OFF
TAKE THEM TO THE PARADE OR
CEREMONY IN YOUR TOWN.
IT'S THE GUYS WHO GAVE
EVERYTHING.
THERE IS VETERANS DAY.
TODAY IS MEMORIAL DAY.
>> JULY 4TH HAS A GREAT
PARADE IN EVERY SMALL TOWN I
HAVE EVER LIVED IN.
>> I LIKE ALL THE KIDS WHO
ARE IN THE COUNTRY COME TOLL
FATHER'S DAY.
>> Greg: THAT'S A LOT OF
KIDS FOR GERALDO.
>> NOW WITH THE GRAND KIDS
IT'S FUN.
>> Kimberly: KICKOFF TO
SUMMER WOULD BE THE HOT TUB.
FEELS LIKE SUMMER, HAPPY.
>> Greg: HAVE IT FOR THE
WINTER?
>> Kimberly: IT DOES, YES.
WHEN YOU GET OUT YOU ARE
STILL WARM AND THEN YOU CAN
HAVE LITTLE SNACKS IN THE
HOT TOWN.
HOT TUB BE CAREFUL ABOUT IT
BEFORE YOU DO.
HOT TUB.
>> Greg: TABLE OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> Kimberly: I DON'T HAVE A
HAMSTER.
>> Greg: FABIO.
>> Kimberly: 100 PERCENT AS
LONG AS HE PUTS HIS HAIR
BACK IN A PONYTAIL.
QUESTION FROM ELTZ ROTH,
SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
VACATION LOCATION AND DO YOU
PREFER SUMMER, DANA, OR
WINTER VACATION?
>> Dana: OH, SUMMER
VACATIONS AND WHERE DO I GO?
I LIKE TO GOAL EVERYWHERE.
BUT I HAVE COME TO HAVE A
LOT OF AFFECTION FOR THE
JERSEY SHORE.
RIGHT.
AND BAY HEAD.
AND SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> Greg: WHAT'S THE ADDRESS?
>> Kimberly: CHECK
INSTAGRAM.
>> Dana: FEEL LIKE IT'S
SUMMER WHEN I HEAD BACK IT
WEST TO WYOMING.
IT FEELS LIKE SUMMER BECAUSE
I SPENT MY YOUTH THERE.
>> Kimberly: PICTURES ARE
BEAUTIFUL.
CHECK OUT HER INSTAGRAM.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, GREG?
>> Greg: I THINK YOU KNOW
THE ANSWER.
MY FAVORITE PLACE IS HOME.
GUY NOWHERE.
I DON'T LEAVE.
TO ME, I CAN CREATE AN
ENTIRE VACATION IN MY HEAD
WITHOUT HAVING TO GET ON A
PLANE.
I HATE TRAVELING.
SO, THAT'S MY.
>> Kimberly: WHEN HE
VACATIONS EVERYONE SUFFERS.
YOU WOULD THINK HE WOULD
COME BACK SUNNY DISPOSITION.
HE COMES BACK CRANKY.
>> Dana: I THOUGHT YOU LIKED
THAT MEXICO PLACE.
>> Greg: I COME BACK WITH
SOME KIND OF ILLNESS.
LAST TIME I WENT TO MEXICO I
HAD A BULLS EYE BRUISE AND I
HAD TO TAKE FOUR WEEKS OF
ANTIBIOTIC FOR THAT.
>> Kimberly: YOU GOT RING
WORM OR SOMETHING DIVUT GUT
I GOT RING WORM FROM CAMP.
EVERY TIME I COME BACK
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH ME.
THE WORLD IS DANGEROUS.
>> Kimberly: G.I. DISORDER.
>> Greg: INSIDE IS THE BEST
PLACE.
WE EVOLVED AS HUMAN BEINGS
TO CREATE OUR OWN DWELLINGS.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO OUTSIDE
ANYMORE.
>> YOU ARE A CAVE DWELLER?
>> Greg: I AM.
>> Pete: EVERY DAY IS A
VACATION DAY FOR YOU.
WORK DAY VACATION DAY GUT
GUDMUNDSSON
.UDMUNDSSON
>>DMUNDSSON
>> GUNDSSON
>> GreDSSON
>> Greg:SON
>> Greg: IN
>> Greg: I'M TAKING OFF THIS
DAY RIGHT NOW AND YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT.
>> Kimberly: A BAR ON NINTH
AVENUE AND WRITING YOUR
BOOK.
I KNOW YOU SO WELL.
LIKE THE NEWLY WED GAME.
>> Pete: I LIKE SUMMER
VACATIONS IN WINTER.
GOING SOME PLACE WRONG IN
WINTER TIME LIKE MEXICO.
LAST TIME I WAS IN MEXICO I
GOT A TATTOO.
DID YOU GO THERE AND COME
BACK LIKE SOME GUY ON THE
CORNER.
>> Greg: GOT MORE THAN A
TATTOO.
>> Dana: VERY SAFE PLACE TO
GET A TATTOO.
>> Pete: IT WASN'T.
BUT EVERYTHING WORKED OUT
OKAY.
>> Kimberly: GOT TO CHASE IT
WITH SOME ANTIBIOTICS.
>> I HAVE BEEN TRAVELING ALL
MY LIFE.
HALF CENTURY I HAVE BEEN ON
THE TELEVISION NEWS BUSINESS
AND I HAVE SEEN BASICALLY
THE WHOLE GLOBE.
ERIKA IS SO MUCH YOUNGER AND
NOW 12 YEARS OLD.
DOING ALL OF THE PLACES I
LIKE PARIS THIS JUNE.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S NICE.
YOU LOVES THAT VISIT ALL THE
TOURIST SPOTS.
>> Kimberly: EIFFEL TOWER.
>> ACTUALLY HAVING DINNER IN
THE EIFFEL TOWER AGAIN.
>> Dana: MOUNT RUSHMORE.
>> I DON'T THINK SO I WILL
TAKE HER THERE.
THAT'S MOTORCYCLE.
>> Greg: JUST GO TO EPCOT
CENTER AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GO ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> Kimberly: YOU JUST BECAME
TRAVEL AGENT.
>> Greg: ALL THE FOOD AROUND
THE WORLD YOU NEVER HAVE TO
LEAVE.
>> Kimberly: I WOULD SAY
FAVORITE VACATION IS MEXICO.
I'M NO LONGER ALLOW YOU HAD
THERE.
TOO MANY ENGAGEMENTS.
I HAVE TO FIND A NEW ONE.
>> Pete: BUILT A WALL TO
KEEP ME FROM GOING OVER.
[LAUGHTER]
SO WE HAVE GOT TIME FOR ONE
MORE.
PLEASE DO A SPEED ROUND ON,
THIS GREG.
PUT THE PEDAL TO THE METAL
ON THIS.
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE PAST
TIME WHEN YOU HAVE SOME TIME
OOFF?
THIS IS FROM --
>> Dana: I KNOW THE ANSWER.
HOME OR AT THE LOCAL BAR,
WINE, WRITING A BOOK.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
>> Kimberly: FOLLOWED BY
COMPLAINING.
>> Greg: FOLLOWED BY
EMBARRASSING DRUNKEN TWEETS
I HAVE TO ANSWER FOR THE
NEXT DAY.
>> Greg: WHY?
>> Pete: WHY NOT?
>> Greg: ME
>> Greg: PLEASE DO NOT DO
THIS ANYMORE.
EXECUTIVE.
>> Kimberly: NEW BAN
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE PAST
TIME.
>> Dana: I LOVE HANGING OUT
WITH FRIENDS MY DOG AND
PETER.
I LOVE TO READ FICTION.
>> Kimberly: YOU LOVE TO GO
TO THE BEACH WITH JASPER.
>> Dana: I DO.
>> Greg: READ THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
>> Dana: FAKE NEWS.
>> Kimberly: PETE?
>> Pete: THROWING THE
FOOTBALL AROUND WITH THE
KIDS ON THE BEACH, THE POOL.
FOOD, DRINKS, KNOCK.
THE SUN.
JUST TOTALLY SHUT IT DOWN.
MAYBE READ A BOOK.
>> Greg: DON'T GO THAT FAR.
>> Pete: READ A FEW PAGES.
>> Kimberly: BOYS LOVE TO
PLAY FOOTBALL AND THEY ARE
QUITE GOOD.
>> I LOVE BEING ON THE
WATER.
TOOK MY BOAT UP THE HUDSON
RIVER AND ERIE CANAL TO
CLEVELAND.
I LOVE BEING ON THE BOAT.
>> Kimberly: FAVORITE PAST
TIME I LOVE TO READ.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
ALSO I LOVE TO GO TO THE
PARK.
THAT'S VERY FUN.
>> Greg: WHAT PARK AND WHAT